[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin und hoher see eigentlich
bin ich nicht und ich bin zu hause
weiter ihres bin ich zu hause so dass
ich mein zweites zuhause
immer wenn die murat mich zuhause nervt
und auch so wenn ich lust drauf habe
gehe ich einfach zu er ist dir ich meine
freundin aus speyer und sie hat hier ihr
kind still ex mädchen und ihr
wunderschönes rotes haus richtig toll
und wer hierher kommt kann man
entspannen man kann das essen was
trinken basteln werkeln liebe und
freundschaft teilen als und ich bin hier
echt super gerne und die ihres ist was
ganz besonderes ich habe sehr einmal in
meinem buch vorgestellt in sallys
classics war das geld weil da haben wir
das titelfoto hier gemacht und die ihres
macht hier wären kurse also richtig cool
da kann man herkommen und einfach hoch
stapeln und heute ist das ganz
besonderes heute ist nämlich der
hundertste workshop das ist doch
unglaublich guten nicht ganz zwei jahren
mischt dauert zwei jahren jedes
wochenende voll und es macht einfach
jedes mal super viel spaß und heute
haben wir den 100 workshops und bisschen
intern sind freunde der familie ist da
also ich und und ihr dürft heute einfach
ein bisschen zu schauen was es hier so
alles passiert sie haben sich jetzt
schon ein paar versammelt ich zeige euch
hier ein passendes grundstück und später
werde ich zwei etagen bauen und die
bekommt ihr also da machen wir später
eine ganz tolle verlosung aber jetzt
zeige ich erst mal ein bisschen was
macht mein lieblingsplatz aber ich komme
wieder ich komme wieder
[Musik]
raus aus da war jetzt gehen wir in den
opa werner ich weiß hat sich komisch an
aber ich zeige euch werte opa werner ist
und zwar der hier so cool wenn ich bin
die einzige toben rausgucken kann alle
anderen murat zum beispiel nur bis da
aber hier ist es richtig cool das ist
doch mal rein kommen und schauen und da
kann man auch darin schlafen und die
nachteile bringen da gibt es alles was
man braucht toilette hat sich hier auch
nebenan richtig richtig süß und das ist
hier der lieblingsplatz von ella ella
kommt man hierher und kocht hier unten
läuft dann hier hoch da hat er alex mit
die linie 1 brandt haus gebaut
am sandstrand und das spielzimmer und im
sommer kann sie direkt von hier oben
runter rutschen who in den pool ist es
nicht cool und mama hatte liegt aber
trüben neben der ehre
wir schlafen dann und leckere selbst
gemachte limonade und können uns nun
ausruhen zeigt die iris uns ihren
workshop raum winter im dunkeln im
kalten kann man nämlich hier runter ja
so wenn es draußen kalt ist dann sind
wir einfach hier und dann wird hier der
workshop gemacht für ungefähr bis
wieviele personen zehn bis zwölf
personen
von oktober bis april und april sind wir
dann wieder oben winterzeit sommerzeit
genau und manchmal er ist ein guter ist
die leute die ihm im winter da sind die
buch dann für das sommer erklärt das
noch mal beides erlebt
er ist gemacht richtig wenn ich bin
zurück ein strich liegt sagen wir mal
also ihres und ich wir bauen jetzt schon
mal die zwei taschen für euch kurier ist
sehe ich aus wie die schwarzwälder
mädels damit eine drei gruppen auf dem
reifen sind das heißt eine schwarze
pompons bedeutet verheiratet oder
bonbons ledig und frankreich seien ich
weiß es nicht
doch es heißt ja wenn ich die iris sorgt
sehr gut manchmal einen klassischen
fernseh genau 33 genau
wir machen ja kann man dann selber aus
das heißt man kann sich hier dass das
geschirr tasche aussuchen teile
aussuchen und dann ausgestellt und dann
bauen und dann ruhe und drei
verschiedene farben an gestänge rosa
gold und silber und dann ja sehr schön
das ist jetzt so der klassiker okay und
jetzt fans und all star schon jetzt
ständig mit holzmacher weiß hat stellt
doch mal zusammen
aber grad für die kombi wir halt auch
schön gelb lässt es um das geld nehmen
uns die zwischen es wäre auch als
klassisches schön und gut
das ist alles so süß das ist das ist
meine lieblings konnten das bei euch
[Musik]
wie schön dass ich kommen dürfte ein
museums menschen fast jeder die haben
sie im keller die ich weiß es nicht
das ist ein klassischer und da hast du
noch eine bundes machen mit zu mehr
farbe und ihr könnt auch was mit welcher
robotern sein täterin firma war
behindert genau welches kommst ich würde
sogar dann haben das geld noch mal mit
drin oder das nehmen wir
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich mich vergessen habe ich nehme
keine reklamationen
[Applaus]
er glaube ich alle einzelteile zusammen
für zwei etagen und jetzt bei euch für
euch
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt kam zusammen nochmals zusammen und
genau du machst die rechts und nicht
links ok du machst fernsehen ich mache
politik
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dollar sehr schön
beide wunderschöne war beide sehr
unterschiedlich geld also am liebsten
würde ich sie euch ja voll gepackt
verlosen mit keksen und das muss dann
jeder selber räumen genau das kann ich
kann nur die rezepte liefern
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hatte iris ich bin sehr begeistert ist
auch ich würde am liebsten selbst
behalten ich auch aber ich esse geht es
mir immer beim gebaut werden würde es am
liebsten selbst behalten ich muss dazu
sagen ich will keine werbung für die
ehre machen weil wenig werbung mache ich
immer ausgebucht und wenn ich dann noch
werbung macht ihres einkommen mehr leute
noch weniger zeit für mich wichtig
deswegen keine werbung keine werbung
ich habe die etagen gebaut doch das
müsst ihr einfach mal erleben also wer
hierher kommt kommt in eine ganz andere
weise das ist echt wunderschön hier geht
es ja nur in workshops sondern auch mal
naturkosmetik oder mal kurz die am pool
also richtig schön ja und es werden
immer mehr also die lust auf workshops
ich enorm ja kann ich ein paar termine
für mich blocken ja wurde dann sein
jeder scheint perfekt
falls er die etagere die sich hier
gewinnen möchtet dann schreibt einfach
klassisch in die kommentare ich möchte
die klassische gewinnen oder funky wenn
sie genau könnt ihr ein schreiben und
ist nicht super schön hier noch ein
platz verlosen
und schau dir lust hat mitzumachen könnt
ihr eine person für 242 genau sehr gut
dann schreibt in die kommentare jene
männer die männer waren hier auch schon
3333 der vierte hier genau und jung ist
ein abschied stattfand hier schon
stadtgeburtstag fand ich schon ziemlich
wild also hier auf der sandburg gibt
sehr viel zu erleben also schön ist
eingeschaltet habe ich hoffe euch
gefällt dieses video wenn ja hat und
schreibt einfach in die kommentare
wir haben jetzt einen schönen abend hier
und unser sonnenschirm geld du darfst
zwei haben machen
[Gelächter]
und alle so hey warum steht sie im
gebüsch
sie steht da immer dafür wieder die
sonne rein lassen
ich danke dir ich würde gerne unter
rutscht aber dann noch nicht im pool und
ich habe keinen bikini da war jetzt hat
sie sich nicht mein scharf abgebremst
[Musik]
so herzlich willkommen
[Gelächter]